douglas y était ce professeur de droit
et spécialiste en sciences politiques
américaines bonjour et merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors s
ou peut parler d'un échec majeur pour
donald trump
oui oui c'est une réprimande biparti
c'est ça qui probablement une plus
douloureuse pour le président parce que
le cndd a annulé le veto mais en plus il
y avait une scierie des échecs dans les
instances maintenant contrôlée par les
républicains dans le cour suprême en
décembre le cour suprême a rejeté de
bloquer les bulletins de vote y même
mike pence
son vice président a refusé du soap et
le processus électoral qui va se passer
le 6 janvier il est collège de grands
électeurs ont déjà voté
et donc maintenant le saut entoure ces
serres autour d'eux le nook 2 donnant
rond comment on peut expliquer ce
revirement parce qu'on a enfin donald
trump s'est souvent ventées du soutien
des républicains
oui les républicains sont 30 fast une
grande dilemme
parce que trompe c'est toujours le
faiseur de roi
il a son base électorale il ya les
élections qui vont se passer et
tremblent à cibler les gens qui le
trahit loyauté c'est le terrain central
de son administration
mais seul autre côté il y a un
gouvernement qui va se faire et c'est
pour éviter la fermeture du gouvernement
dimanche c'est le dernier un jeu de
l'année congressional tout le monde
prendre leurs vacances ici elle ne votez
pas cette loi alors les gosses ennuis
dans le gouvernement le fonctionnement
administratif
il s'appelle lourdement sur les membres
du congrès qu'est ce qui posait
exactement problème pour de notre pont
mais vaut bien cet article 230 qui
permet aux réseaux sociaux de signaler
la diffusion de contenus mensonger
qu'est ce qui posait problème du point
de vue de
trump sur cet article maintenant
j'active en saas des gaffes les grandes
sociétés comme google facebook amazon
qui il se sent sont maintenant sur le
parti démocrate
c'est pas vrai mais c'est son sentiment
qu'il y a des ennemis et cette loi
contient une provision
c'est un projet de défense mais il ya
toujours les petits articles ajoutés
pour les raisons politiques
cet article d'un bouclier contre la
responsabilité de ces grandes sociétés
il voulait mettre en responsabilité
l'habilité responsabilité civile ces
sociétés pour le menacer
parce que maintenant sans le pouvoir du
président il est en face de la furie qui
l'a le peu qu'il a enflammé ou disait en
lait les élus de son propre parti à
donald trump sont de plus en plus
nombreux à reconnaître sa défaite à
l'élection présidentielle et de la trump
avait dénoncé en début de semaine un
leadership républicain faible et fatigué
vous êtes d'accord avec ça waouh
il y a plusieurs propositions grand ça
oui mais tu fais contrôler ces faibles
et fatigué et en plus il
si les républicains le choeur les deux
sièges les deux sénateurs en georgie
nick macklon ne soit plus président du
sénat métro a toujours son soutiennent
dans leur chambre des représentants et
là on avait un grand nombre de
représentants des députés qui vont voter
le 6 janvier pour un procès de bloquer
le voir des grands électeurs et à ce
moment là il y a aussi un sénateur
républicain qui le rejoindre et donc
deux heures de débat les chiffres 6
janvier et on va voir les couleurs que
montrent les républicains en bien trop
une dernière question vous glace et s
avec ce camouflet ce qu'on peut dire que
le président élu joe biden gagne en
popularité ou alors est ce qu'on peut
considérer que c'est juste en vogue
entre guillemets en titre up ouais on
n'a pas toujours les sondages l'opinion
populaire mais si le passé est
indicative de l'avenir sont base va
continuer à se soutiennent dans l'antre
amp et l'idée que les élites de
washington ont rejeté réfusé réprimées
dans le temps ne fait que se souder son
soutiennent parmi son propre base merci
beaucoup au douglas y est pour toutes
ces précisions je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur de droit et spécialiste en
sciences politiques américaines merci